i remember looking at a forum that um
was talking about different
uh armor types that you can get in mass
effect and they were like
you know is it worth you know buying
such and such armor from the specter
requisition it's super expensive but
is it really valuable and someone was
like
or you know is it is it basically worth
it and
and somebody was like just play the game
bro you do you
and i was i just remember thinking not
helpful what what yeah what
what do you think this person is
basically doing that like
they essentially are playing the game it
just happens to be on reddit right now
but
that is an extension of the game yeah um
and i just remember thinking what a
hilarious like somebody
sitting there logging in going i need to
reply to this person to let them know
that
that they're just just do you bro i'm
trying to
which is my choice of doing me is being
informed thanks
for a developer now i do yeah you're
you're you're the man
so yeah is that i don't even speak to
this
is that part of it like are there people
that go hey part of this game is going
to be
the extracurricular extemporaneous
things that happen outside of our actual
is do you think that's true emergent
gameplay is when it bleeds out over into
social and everything else i definitely
can't speak to that in terms of
the company that i work for however i've
done a number of interviews like
i made uh several many documentaries at
ign
meaning i've just interviewed a lot of
developers and that's absolutely a thing
the ones that i always find really
interesting are when they are
intentionally
um trying to get cosplay around certain
characters and how they approach that
like borderlands yeah like borderlands
did it like really specifically was like
yes this was made with cosplay in mind
uh but there are loads of them that do
that they're like we just really want to
see people dress up as these characters
so
like i wonder like how if if that's from
a marketing team i don't know
but how difficult that is i've always
been like how do you even approach that
they're like lots of stuff
and usually colors like oh that would be
it has to be internal right because like
in that example you're talking about
that impacts design that impacts
character modelers that impacts the
animation that impacts everything else
marketing is also always used yeah way
too late yeah
there was like okay what do you got like
we have these things like we'll make it
work
i'm sure marketing comes in with like
extra armor
like pre-order bonus armor that could be
a thing that potentially doesn't start
with the dev team and starts much later
than that
but if it's a big enough project to
throw out can you go ahead and if we
if we monetize it can you throw it back
in they're like okay
it's true if it's a sufficiently big
project though marketing is involved
from day one
like they're involved from day one but i
mean
as far as like they're i don't know
first of all i'm not talking out on my
ass necessarily but i'm certainly not
as qualified to speak to this as most
but just
my experience has been it's always like
we get involved and then we go away you
make your game and they
come in and there's like they hit the
milestones
depending on the studio they aren't even
actually involved from day one they're
just
told so they would be told what is being
worked on
but they wouldn't actually have any say
in anything at all
but if it's a if it's a huge budget no
i've just
i've been a fly on the wall to these
conversations before where
marketing basically has to
be one of several sign offs on big
decisions because
they are the ones that are going to be
tasked with selling this
and if they look at something and go
we have no idea what that is what that
means or this
character is super off-putting
everyone's going to have very
different takes and different project
leaders are going to have certain
um iron fists that are more
um sort of empowered than others but
i've i've seen it happen where
i guess that depends on the publisher
like definitely doesn't happen for all
of them
yeah no of course not of course not but
and it's also only a phenomenon
of those that are being built from the
ground up
in those kinds of circumstances because
it's not like
uh an indie that then goes and signs a
publisher
is going to be doing that kind of level
of
running interference so late in the
process i think it would be more like a
marketing of the publisher looks at it
and goes we either can or can't
confidently sell this
and that's kind of what determines if
they pick up the game
there's there's also like there's there
was a title that i was in
where marketing got involved and said
we need the main character the
protagonist
to look like a hero and so they were
they were definitely participating in
the conversation of
character design with the intention of
what's going to look good on a cover box
right
and we would we had already started
shooting and we had already started you
know
we were down the production pipeline a
lot but we had a rough character level
but as far as like
okay what is the actual character model
really gonna look like right now we've
kind of mock-up we have a whip
that we're able to move around in in 3d
space and
within these scenes especially but also
as a as a
it's grayscale at that point but they
were going
no and they're looking at it's kind of
very similar to the way that the film
world works
where it's like color of eyes color of
hair
height um all of those things and
really you know um needling on the
nuances
of wrinkles and stuff like that as
opposed to
um and then that of course speaks to
like well what's our level of fidelity
like are we able
to support across the board is that only
in the cinematics does that happen
so i mean i i've seen how marketing can
get involved
there so i guess you're right it's not
it's not always a
cut in case i just found a pen oh
exciting for you
it's always interesting because it's so
often presented as if it's this very
adversarial
kind of dynamic where the developers are
the kind of
you know pure artistes and the marketing
people are like the cold-hearted
corporate types coming in and mucking
with it but i've always seen it as
like marketing is looking at it from the
angle of can we convince people that
this is worth
them buying totally and if if we
if we like so we're it's sort of like
help me help you
kind of thing um and the more the
developers want that game to sell like i
don't think that's inherently a bad
thing i think where marketing
really screws things up is you know
demanding
release dates too early or demanding a
thing release at all
too early like those are those are the
common
marketing annoyances it it and it's a
that's a real challenge
you know what is that is that
marketing's called we've talked about
this a little bit before
i don't know if that's if it also
depends on the studio but sometimes yes
i i would say and by the way people who
work in marketing or pr
look we are equal opportunity
disparagers
[Laughter]
that's the thing i don't think we're
disparaging i don't know like
everybody's trying to do their best
it's just there's i firmly believe that
i think that everybody is doing their
best job there are
inherent unique challenges to every
aspect of this industry whether it be
from design
marketing or whatever i i feel my i can
only speak to my personal experience of
course but
i i have seen the the
skewedest be off more when it comes not
to marketing but
pr so which involves marketing but it's
pr
going we feel like this is what we're
going to do and with this is the event
that we're going to have
and this is the approach that we're
taking whereas marketing
is trying to like you said what's the
best way to sell this game and pr is
like well here's a great execution of
that
idea i feel like i wouldn't pr yeah i
would think that happens again it
totally changes depending on the studio
but like marketing takes what you have
and it's like okay i'll figure out how
to sell what you have where pr can be
like i'm gonna change what you have
actually
that that's that's probably a thing it's
uh
i mean definitely is again and every
single
publisher is different like i always
wonder if do you think that rockstar
has to talk to take two
in the early stages of anything they do
or just take to just go
hi sorry sorry i just want to see what's
going on with you i understand you're
gonna make the most expensive game of
the maid
again but uh you know do we need to see
anything
i just trust them yeah i think there are
some relationships that are slightly
more privileged than others after a
certain point
yeah i think that is the team i would
guess definitely wagging the dog
yeah yeah i feel like that one they
probably get to do kind of whatever they
want
but i don't know it is we we don't have
a pr marketing person on the podcast
uh we're missing play watch listen
promote
we need to add someone from that field
play watch listen sell
yeah i mean my biggest understanding of
that again from even the people i know
who work in marketing at pr is that it
is super different depending on the
publisher like way way way different i
know that
easy is really involved i would
i would say like you could break it down
a granular level like it's going to be
the publisher the studio and the title
right like there's there's some people's
like just because you're a
sony or just because you're an
activision you know or whatever
depending upon where you fall in their
pecking order and then depending upon
what's what what title you're going to
be that that's that's going to be like
we don't have the marketing spend
that whatever has we have this
um like i wouldn't want a game like
i'm trying to think of a of a nice
sony first party developer that is
definitely skewing to be like either
finch you know
or not that's not a first party but i
mean like something like that's that's
that's more artistic to have the same
kind of i wouldn't want to see it on the
side of a bus
i wouldn't want to see that you know how
was journey marketed austin
uh
it was definitely not marketed
um its success is not a reflection of
its marketing it had a runaway word of
mouth
uh it was not like it it got
you know trailer placement and it got
media coverage
and things but there were no big
billboards there were nothing
there were no buses there were no uh you
know
ad buys that i'm that i can remember in
terms of like big play
i don't even remember big featured like
you know the equivalent today it was
amazing how it was so different even
just nine years ago but the equivalent
today
of like center stage at
you know the game awards kind of thing
or like a big gamescom
unveiling like erica did or whatever
like
i i don't even recall because it was i
think it
i think it was largely reliant on
[Music]
um the fact that flower
had built up you know the the pedigree
of that game company within the
kind of the the more niche
world of the indie i've always found it
weird thinking of that game as an indie
but but within the space of people that
are not
necessarily only looking at the god of
wars and uncharteds that were
going on at the time um i think that
flower kind of paved the way but then
honestly the thing that i remember was
just
when the review embargo dropped and like
a thousand reviews came out all at once
that were like 10 out of 10 this is the
one of the most striking things i've
ever played ever in my life and it was
just like
when something had that you know it's
like when lightning strikes 10 feet away
from you
it's just this it just shakes the whole
world yeah
and so that my my impression was that
return on investment from a marketing
standpoint had to be
one of the best they've ever had because
i really don't remember a big marketing
push at all in fact
funny enough um usually the way i come
into these conversations
often is that soundtrack albums are
basically an extension of marketing
um they used to be a far more powerful
one because you would get like
so and so famous artists to contribute
something and then the
album became its own activation point
in marketing speak uh for people to get
into it and so
you know that was the reason why the the
the end credit song
became a thing back in the day you know
30 plus years ago
um it was that was marketing that was
record
record deal radio wow it was record
companies making deals
because they realized we could have a
hit
song that drives people to check out the
movie and
also is like uh you know at in its
heyday
talking in like the 70s and 80s uh even
into the 90s
the the notion of the film single the
hit song from the movie
could generate outrageous amounts of
money
that's just like bonus for the movie you
know millions of dollars so
um that the whole idea of soundtrack
albums as an extension of marketing
um is kind of where they come from
really because this
music that's why when you go back
especially and you listen like all these
specialty record labels that do
old scores that never got soundtrack
albums you know like for example there's
a label that
did a bunch of episodic scores from the
twilight zone tv show
and we go back and like that was never
ever released like they never did
soundtrack albums for tv
in general but they definitely didn't do
it for a show like that
and so um they you go back and you
listen and the recordings are you know
they're a little iffy in places like
there's wrong notes here and there
you can hear like a page turn and say
because they were like
you can't hear it in the context of how
it's mixed into the show and no one ever
expected this stuff to be released on
its own so it was
it was it was those details were
irrelevant and it's they would never do
that now because it's just this
presumption
that everything is going to get released
but but now you know the marketing
support soundtrack album thing
represents you know
it represents far lower stakes than it
used to because
does that mean to you that you always
sign up for two jobs that you're always
signing up
to score the game and then release an
album
very often yeah and sometimes they are
separate contracts right uh
they are you know and and and they're
often
or will put like a bunch of language
that says we'll figure out the
soundtrack album later and make a
separate deal because
especially now in the game world you
know there's there's all these things to
consider you know there's all the
streaming domains
there's twitch uh and like how we gonna
navigate that and potential
um you know like is there a label
involved that might be doing copyright
notices or takedowns those kinds of
things um
and then there's also um
uh the the bundling potential like if we
can put this on steam
like where you you know add an extra
buck
or whatever and you can get the album
that way like there's there's a whole
lot that goes into it that we don't
know the landscape of often when we're
at the beginning of a project and just
starting it so
but i can tell you i've i've had
album edit revision notes and i've had
album art
like i'll go commission an artist and
i'll get album art revision notes
from the marketing of the game because
they're like
you commission august for the album if i
can i prefer to
usually because i always like to make
album art especially if we're talking
about vinyl i really prefer that album
art be
an expression of something yeah unique
and parallel to the game not just a
reuse of the
main like box art or key art or whatever
uh to me it's uninteresting i prefer
you finally this little opportunity i've
been an attack by a dog she kept making
noise out there
she's gonna come in here eventually you
want to come up here
come on she's buried this is our stand
mike really loves those chin rubs
i was wondering how long it would take
for her to open the door
she doesn't like being alone it's like
the velociraptors in the kitchen
like you know exactly got the dramatic
close-ups
she's like i lied yeah she barks
no vowels anyway makes sense to me else
and i just wouldn't have known that you
you did that i feel like
you're and you know the funny your job
of all of our jobs requires
so many um
investments like i don't feel like
i guess troy would have to like a lot of
voice actors you'd need to like go
through the effort of buying a booth
especially
post pandemic but i don't need to
buy anything to write i got in a
motorbike accident couldn't even use my
hands and i was still working because i
could use my fingers like this
i just couldn't use my thumbs i didn't
need anything
like it seems so comparatively cheap to
be a writer versus a composer
in that way funny enough this is why
i i i was gonna mention something else
about journey in the marketing so
help me remember but i will say as a as
a
as a as a hard tangent off of that what
you're
sort of tapping into and peeling the
curtain back on is why
by federal court
edict in the u.s composers are forbidden
from unionizing
because we are basically considered
management and not labor because we
oversee so much production that's nuts
um and and but in a way it makes total
sense like because then you hire
the notion of like the romantic idea of
i'm going to sit down with my pad of
paper
you know my staff paper and write some
sheet music
or a little mikey and give people the
content they want
um the notion that i basically just kind
of
write it and and then ship it off and it
gets it gets recorded and all whole
process kind of
manages itself like those days are for
all intents and purposes
um done for uh
you know there used to be the old days
of the studio music department the
composer delivers the sheet music
essentially the music department says we
got it from here
and some studios sony most noteworthy
uh in the game world operate a bit like
that like the sony
csg creative services group really does
administer like if you look
at the behind the scenes of everything
from
you know ghost of tsushima the last of
us returnal
every every sony title that it's the
same
handful of people you'll see recurring
in all of those
from the sony side of it because they
are extremely hands-on
with the music production for all sony
titles they don't just
say to the composer you know bring us a
finished product however you get there
we'll get there like they they actually
steer the ship they're very atypical in
that way even
you prefer that or i guess it would
depend on the person but
does that take so much freedom it it
does
take some freedom away but at in
exchange for
collaborative partners who know what
they're doing um like i've i've worked
with
those folks before and i i count them as
good friends and they're
they're magnificent at what they do uh
so i've i you know i've done i've done
that dance with them and i've enjoyed it
and i've also done the you know just
like leave me to my own devices
um approach i mean like ubisoft was an
extreme example
where on syndicate i mean i was
literally
recording at abbey road for a week and
they didn't even there wasn't even
anyone from ubisoft there normally
there'd be a whole
there'd be a whole entourage of in sort
of invested stakeholders
yeah you know they're part of the
process in the booth giving feedback
you know i remember when we were on
journey even on a title a
fraction of the size even on journey
remember when we were recording the
orchestra and the music producer for
sony is
you know saying well you know take four
from the orchestra at bar seven i i
wasn't happy with how they sounded
in terms of you know the e flats being
in tune can we get another take you know
and it's like
and there's a title the fraction of the
size of
of it and ubisoft was like you know
let's just send us the final mixes yeah
wow
does that mean that you think that in
order to be a good composer you would
also need to have good management skills
it's hard to imagine a lot the composers
that i know that are
successful that don't feel
as confident in that either do
everything themselves
like they they they rarely
work the way i do like they are largely
like a good example of this off the top
of my head
and this is actually not an implication
of her management skills because i
i don't have any idea her management
skills but sarah schachner
is somebody who the vast majority of
what you hear of her work is
like home brew she's got a giant
mountainous
wall of of vintage and analog and
current uh synthesizers and she cooks up
everything
cool organically she also plays a bunch
of instruments so she
tracks herself playing and so the idea
of spending huge amounts of time she has
done orchestral recordings like on call
of duty
um and so it's not that she can't do it
or that it's just
when you think of her stuff you think of
you know the handful of assassin's creed
games that she's done and
and um and um what was the bioware
uh anthem uh like it's very electronic
uh and so there's somebody where
management is rarely
a job necessity for someone like or
darren corp shows another good example
darren
darren does everything himself with
almost no acceptance i imagine
mickelson should be like that too
i think to us i think to and yeah
and i i don't know precisely his process
um but i would imagine it's not
dissimilar to darren's but then yeah
someone
who's like me you know obviously
management is
an is a crucial part of the equation
there are also some composers that have
like
business partners that are kind of like
the producer
half where their job is to write the
music and the producer
management type is who they delegate all
that to uh like for example i remember
john debney who i used to share a studio
with who's done a million he
he's dabbled in games here and there
like he famously did that
that ill-fated sony game the dragon
riding one called
lair uh that they they spent an ungodly
boatload of money
on and it ended up tanking quite hard um
but he wrote a big grand old-fashioned
score
for that ages ago this was a ps3 game um
but he
um he's mostly done movies like he works
a lot with john favreau and and
and he's done a million romantic
comedies and john
um he and his wife beyond being
a happily married couple are also like
business partners in that way where
if i have any question for john that is
remotely
outside of the immediate domain of like
why f sharp
is the tempo too fast on this queue uh
lola is
is kind of in charge she's the one you
know coordinating i mean they obviously
work together but
she's the point of contact so that he
can focus on the music and there are
other composers i know
winifred uh phillips who's worked on she
did one of the ac
um kind of the big you know those big
like expansions that they did i can't
remember which
one that she did um
but uh like freedom it wasn't freedom
cry but you know those
like not quite full-sized ac games that
are nonetheless
like huge expansions um she did one of
those she also worked on a bunch of the
um
the little big planet stuff she has a
producer
who is i think del like winifred's job
is to write the music and the producer
whose name is escaping me
her job is everything else as far as i
can i don't know winifred particularly
well but
so some people yeah they find they find
somebody
that's really common for writers as well
to have writing partners that's less
so the yeah probably i mean it could
actually be
having one of them do management or
outreach or whatever else and then the
other one
do a bulk of the creative work but
two people as a writing team who write
together on absolutely everything is
very very very common i feel like you
don't hear about the two of them as
often but i feel like that is
so frequent that i've always been like i
should find one of those that seems like
that would be a good idea
yeah i have a i have a good friend who
who was a writer on
um star trek discovery um who
is a tag to is half of a writing team
like they individually do their own
things but the va
their whole career so far is as a unit
that has moved around
through a bunch of high-profile tv shows
and stuff and and and
to me that's fascinating there there are
a few composer examples of this like the
newton brothers which is funny because
they're not brothers and they're not
named newton
but um the newton brothers score all of
mike flanagan's stuff so they did the
the
two haunting you know hunting of hill
house haunting of blind manor they did
his
movies like oculus and dr sleep
um and they've done a bunch of other
things there's a new
raid or uh purge the per you know that
franchise i do really want to stop
watching those movies
they're on my list i've never seen a
single one of them either but there's a
new one that's
that's out like right now or about to be
or whatever that they did and
the newton brothers andy grush and
taylor uh
blanking on his life why are they called
the newton brothers then there's a
reason and i can't remember what it is
there is a reason and i am blanking on
what it is but because i always just
knew andy i met him years ago
um that they they are i don't think it's
in their case like one does the writing
ones the business they are
co-composers and i've that's like
they're i don't think they ever do any
i don't think there is any like andy
grush scores out in the world it's all
newton brothers they are a unit
lest it's like a band that's like you
know
it takes the band breaking up before
they do their own things i assume i
i don't know it's pretty rare though
composers tend to
want to kind of do things their way but
one thing i was i was going to say that
i am now relieving you of having to
remind me of
about the marketing and the soundtrack
albums
yes of command i want to be host again
uh
the um the i remember on journey
on uh on journey i remember because
there was no dialogue or
spoken word or anything like their text
or i mean on screen that
i remember genova goes the soundtrack is
like
a spoiler oh look at you already
i felt my perspective very slowly
shifting
um genova goes the soundtrack album is
like a spoiler for the game if you
listened to it before
so ironically normally which is true
like it goes through the emotional arc
and if you experience that before you
play the game it might actually take
away
from the game that was genova's fear um
and that's very so i wonder if that
would have actually happened maybe to
a small number of very perceptive people
or other composers i don't know it
definitely it definitely
tells you like if you listen to the
music you realize oh it has this very
kind of rapturous
ending or at least that's what we hope
you take from it you don't know what's
coming though
if you just play through it i mean you
could kind of intuit it from a
archetypal joseph campbell sense but if
you're just playing it at face value
not knowing where things are going i
think is is more powerful so they
they delayed the soundtrack albums
released like
two or three weeks from when the game
initially came out
um which was also a hilarious bit of
accidental marketing
sort of jiu jitsu because it
it was it built up this massive amount
of demand for the album
so that when it dropped it it dropped
like huge
because the game had developed three
weeks worth of like people getting
excited so it chatted
immediately yeah the album did like
freakishly well for a video game
soundtrack it was lit it was like
the the the the um
billboard charts highest grossing video
game score of all time wow
um nice good job you know well the funny
thing is that
that means like it was 97th or something
on the
chart or whatever he knows it was a
hardly it's like being
as they say the world's tallest dwarf
if i can if i can use an in delicate
perhaps
um but it it it that's what it felt like
it was like it was like being at the
kids table at the wedding reception you
know it was like hey you know
but i made it one here or when kramer
kramer joins the uh
karate class full of all like 12 year
olds in seinfeld
someday you'll sorry doesn't understand
the reference yeah but uh i was gonna
say to jump back to my earlier ascetion
that you did not comment on troy what do
you think is the startup cost
for voice acting is what i said that
correct
like because i've done auditions for
voice acting stuff on my phone
under a blanket yeah or that that's
that's provided
that um you're not going into a studio i
think now things have changed
and you don't have to there's nothing
but for auditions
you wouldn't audition in a studio i
would think yeah but they're okay with
audition from my perspective at least
from
with auditions not sounding perfect
sound quality being bad and we have
spoken about that before though
there are limits i i have not listened
to auditions because the quality was bad
hmm
um and i know for a fact that their
weather even subconsciously
no one's gonna go yeah i could barely
understand it and it was distorted and i
made my ears bleed but there was really
something in the performance that i got
true that is a huge hurdle so i don't
think while you have to have like
pristine audio quality
set yourself up for success don't don't
you know i mean
my phone can record video
in like 4k and
and uh you know with with audio that's
good enough
um i would think right like like if if
at some point it's democratized to the
degree that
anyone who's got like nice lighting and
whatever they're overkill to a point
that they're not
they're probably buying themselves a
fractional percent
edge by by upgrading i know rahul does
his auditions with an iphone
and and speaking of mike flanagan
definitely got the haunting of bligh
mana with an iphone
but no it's for everybody that's that's
what it is just shoot it on your iphone
and send it to me because that's also
what they're going to watch it on
true maybe an ipad yeah right maybe an
ipad
but no one's going to go into a
screening room to watch back you know
audition reels sure so that by the way
there's a there's a whole composer sort
of
like thread there as well of composer
auditions are also listened to
through phones and laptops and we have
to mix
knowing that it's going to come out of
the shittiest speakers ever you have to
mix differently from that
oh for sure you have to mix in a far
more crude
like basically potentially this may be
true as well you may potentially arrange
differently
because if you know you're you couldn't
do this big
low end thing because it's going to drop
off
because most iphone speakers don't carry
anything lower than like
like like 200. i was going to say yeah
100 i was going to be great
generous 100 hertz so you may not you
either
might mix differently or you may not
depend so much on low end
to be able to sell the gravitas and the
base of this
you know thing or you would have to mix
differently understand that people are
not going to live
maybe they're listening to airpods maybe
not
yeah you also have to assume that they
won't listen for long
so you also have to you always have to
get to the point like my my advice for
young composers is always get to the
point in
in under five seconds uh especially
because if they're listening through a
phone and the fidelity is working
against you making someone listen to
something that's not terribly pleasant
of a listening experience just from a
pure
speaker quality perspective in addition
to
taking your time and kind of meandering
there
so that's like it's just it's an
unrealistic aspect so funny that
like my biggest advice for people
applying for writing jobs as someone who
has had to submit samples but has also
had to read a lot of samples
um is don't have typos you wouldn't
believe how frequently people are
applying for writing jobs that have
writing samples that are full of typos
like i would say
75 of them honestly that's the same
thing
within like even pronunciation of words
right um for people who do auditions
i to answer your question there is no
requirement of cost
yeah but people do
if someone does have an agent
there is an inherent level of um
for lack of a better word value or worth
that is associated with that
nobody wants to be the first one to bet
on
but they always want to be the one to
discover you
so if if you have an agent that means
that somebody else has
already bet on you and won you're there
um and without the caveat that there are
some agents out there that
that you know will happily sign some
naive it's really bad for influences the
the
way that agents and marketing managers
can take advantage of them there
they will sign them but they will not
submit them
yeah exactly so an agent an agent is
only every time they send through a
submission
it is because they're vouching for them
because that way
ain't nobody go into a dry well and if
that agent only submits
shitty auditions with bad quality sure
they that they lose their standing and
what every agent wants
is for someone to go don't go to anybody
else go
straight to abc because they all abc
agency always gives us the best people
and that's what you it's not nobody is
out there going well let's just
throw out the net if they're doing that
they've
never cast before ever they're going you
want us
we want to cast a wide net like you're
an idiot because you're gonna give her
if you're like throwing a net over the
side of a [ __ ]
boat are you kidding me you're gonna
pull up shoes
and and dolphins terrible things
dolphins all sorts of [ __ ]
i mean in this analogy i feel like you
want the dolphins
right you want to chuck a spear into the
ocean and get a
swordfish and go it's the dolphin you
get the dolphin but none of them are
dying
by
isn't your analogy this is where i'm
just
making i'm i'm making you regret your
analogy uh
isn't isn't uh the whole point of like
trying to get the most creme de la creme
like if
if you're this hunter you know avoiding
the dolphin is like
avoiding the brilliant actor isn't it
i'm just saying you're the ruthless
person who's dolphin hunting
hunting not so common but i did just
watch
see spiricy and i'm just now in a state
of constant upset
um not netflix documentary see spiricy
it is basically like what that is it uh
i don't think it came out too long ago
but it's basically about
um it was supposed to stop being about
pollution i think and it's actually
about the fishing industry
barbara duncan i'm gonna give her a
shout out to this it was i i haven't
seen this but she tweeted she was like i
don't understand how you call it see
spirit c and how you miss up the
opportunity for
conspiracy
that is a good point i don't know
workshop that for 30 more seconds you
give them far better title
yeah but then if you say it out loud
you're just saying conspiracy
whereas c spirit is a different exactly
i'd be like which one
it's a different title marketing but
you're
already talking about it that's true i'm
already talking about the conspiracy
the documentary on netflix that's not
how people are consuming it's not word
of mouth there's people sitting like
this when they're
going i really which is true that
find those trailers by the way for
netflix such an affront
i mean how it auto plays like yeah the
moment you open netflix
i wish the sound was i wish the sound
was opt in it's i think it used to be
and then at some point it just started
playing back sound apple does it
they're great tedla so season two ladies
and gentlemen so that's my biggest
use of e3 what what ted lasso season two
it's been announced really you guys
haven't seen ted lasso
you're saying it's so funny you're
saying it like you're
i've never it sounds like intentionally
trying to make it
hard for me to know what you're saying
i've noticed too head lasso
i thought time it could be yeah she's
pronouncing it wrong austin
she said ted lasso thank you yeah
ted the show i'm saying tedla
i'm sorry i'm just excited about this
very positive show
that apparently is like a game oh boy
this is cowboy
you have a rope what are you what is
that called
that would be a lesson lso
it's not a french word it's
this is like a game i love playing
s-e-a-u-x
if you if i play if i play a melody note
for note but i radically change the
rhythm
can you still identify it like like
you know
dave
[Music]
i feel like i recognized whatever you
just did
but like star wars
[Music]
that's what ted sounded like to me okay
well i'm sorry
everybody we focused this is the whole
topic that's the name of the episode
conversation too
what there's taco bell
and there's taco bell hmm
what do you go what do you say taco bell
i i'm having a crisis of identity i
don't know what sounds more natural to
me hey where do you go together
the answer wouldn't be talk about i was
going to say
uh you go to um where do you go to get
diarrhea where do you go to get that
chipotle yeah um
the i think i say taco i think i say
taco bell i think it is on the bench
place bell
yeah because you're right it's not one
word it's not like the composer
pachelbel
it's i'm just really excited about the
new season of
ted lawson how are you guys it was one
of the best things to happen at
quarantine
it was like i watched it all over again
what is this
what is your one sentence pitch for that
show i have not seen it and i've been
told i must but what is your one
sentence pitch on why i must it is
just so positive just so positive
[Laughter]
that was pretty good um it's dude it's
uh
what chills that one moment it could
have been so
cheesy it could have been so bad no
spoilers
please it is it is rooney
with with comedy with it's very sad
but at the same time it's just basically
someone who has put in
a very strange position that is
intentionally
kind of orchestrated that is the most
positive person in the world so it
doesn't matter
what happens to them really um without
being fake
it's still something it's just like [ __ ]
is this show is this like a
realistic if butters were an adult show
no
no it's no he's not bottas he's he's
awesome
but he's not naive and the beauty of it
is
i don't give away too much it is give
away nothing
it is sell me on it but tell me nothing
about it
marketing perfect portrait of the
power of the indomitable human spirit
it is it is someone who looks in the
face of adversity and goes
cool it is it is awesome man yeah it is
so good it's really i was like i guess
we'll watch it
and we powered through it and i was like
everybody else
on twitter everything i missed that show
and i wish i could go back and watch it
one more time and i might actually do
that
yeah it's just it made me miss
london though a lot it was just
uh it's very good it's so good yeah
highly recommend it yeah season two july
23rd
that's my biggest uh announcement
on that by the way i'm gonna welcome
everyone to the podcast
43 minutes in let's do it hi everyone
welcome to play watch listen i'm a lot
of a video game writer that's awesome
awesome winter he's a video game that's
trey baker he is a video game actor
mike bithell is not with us here today
and my dog has also left the room so i
should get up and shut the door
are you guys gonna be okay if i just for
a second shut the
okay
oh i did that on purpose i was telling
you not to break anything
i i uh sadly my power has my emergency
chancellor powers
uh were uh take given back to the people
i i have a question that i i i only i
have to go in a minute but uh
um i'm curious
that would be good that would be good
i'm gonna slide out of frame to make
that easy
i saw you troy i saw you you were too
late
i watched it happen
i'd commit harder to this if i had if i
had if i didn't have to go soon i would
i would
i would just stay gone sneak away that
easy
yeah you had a question i'm curious so i
finished
uh resident evil village yeah i was
gonna ask about that it's officially the
first ps5 game that
i've finished nice um
and i'm curious i i remember i got
tagged in this article
um that was one of these weird you know
sort of trying to be a compliment but it
makes you go
what because they phrased it as um a
list of
the top video game scores almost as good
as the games themselves
and they had journey on the list and it
was one of those where i was like
i feel like i understand the
well-intentioned
vibe of that but that feels a little bit
it's mean like a slap in the face
um and like i get what they meant though
what they meant was
music that in their estimation is so
good
it's basically it makes the game almost
redundant to the music listening
experience like the music captures all
of the joy of the game
so thoroughly that you don't even need
the game anymore that's like that's what
they meant but the way they phrased it
was
it's like my favorite fortune cookie
ever said you remind people that there's
other great things in life
like yeah i get it so close but uh
so to that end though and that's in that
spirit ish
um how easily
it my my review
of resident evil will be sort of
implicit in this question but how easily
can you enjoy
a game the two of you when the writing
is really distracting in
resident evil in village i think that
the cheese of it is part of the appeal
so it does not take away from my
enjoyment of that game
whatsoever i was constantly making fun
of ethan
for having one line as 10 seconds too
late
like and really bad ones yeah he kills
somebody and he's like that'll show you
and i'm like yeah you you should tell
them ethan
right right on cue that buddy yeah after
the whole
after the whole boss battle with lady
demystif he's like
he's like no you're who's cursed yeah
and i was like
ages ago as well yeah like she's dead
she's a crystal for
for 30 seconds now yeah similar yeah or
like at the beginning when you
meet the family and they're all kind of
huddling in the house trying to figure
out what to do and then all hell breaks
loose
he's known these people for 15 seconds
and then the girl sees her father come
out of the flame and he she jumps in
after him to save him
and he goes why does everyone i know
keep dying on me and i'm like you don't
know what you don't know them
they i think these are strange the whole
way through there the
thing with the car and then the thing
with trying to make them climb i think
that there were a lot of mistakes that
ethan made in that particular section of
the game but yeah
to resident evil like it actually ended
up the story
ended up being more fulfilling to me
than i expected in the end
um in that spoiler territory so i will
avoid that
but uh no i think the cheesiness of it
made
the kind of cheesy nature of some of the
boss fights
having the dialogue suit that i think
is totally consistent and fun
i i i find it though difficult when like
for example
the the the you know the the
creepy [ __ ] underground hallways with
the
giant baby monster like that
the earnest creepiness of that is
represents a
different vibe from the one-liners to
the point that it
feels like two different games it feels
like the designers and the art team
i think what you're referring to is
basically a different game it is silent
hill
inside of resident evil well that yeah
angela kept saying the same thing she
was like this is so so silent
it is um yeah to me i i just felt like
all the designers and all the like
everyone outside of the
basically the narrative and writing team
brought the a game of like this really
moody great
suspenseful creepy you know
shooter suspense horror game and then
the other people were like it's going to
be hilarious we're going to do this and
this and it was like
i think that's intentional yeah i do
think they intend to do that i mean the
duke is like a really likable
character who i was always excited to
see um i think it's all
so sorry no go ahead i know i
clearly interrupted you i was just gonna
say i think the
intent to give you breaks from the
stress is a very big and
ongoing part of resident evil that's
what safe rooms were
um there are less safe rooms this time
around because there are some places
where you can save that it's not a safe
room
but having moments of dialogue that act
as levity from the tension
are akin to them having safe rooms which
give you a break from the horror
and things are only scary if you have a
break from what's scary sometimes
there's also safe words that's true
thank you troy um
i think it's i think there's also a bit
of uh
is it the ghost is it your ghost so
traveler before
he goes to bed whether he's taking a nap
or whatever loves to play the piano
oh and i love it but troy sent me a
photo of it and it's like
had it was like late at night and and
there was like this
lighting from like blow it was the most
haunted house thing i've ever seen in my
life and i
i'm suddenly not convinced traveler has
ever existed
it was it was the creepiest thing
it's definitely this very like we
happened to capture this moment of the
ghost baby playing me
yeah it was basically that moment in
ghostbusters where they go down into the
library like cardstock in the beginning
and there's
yeah exactly very good um
and then after he gets a blow job later
in the same movie the montage
and he allows it to happen um oh he
loves it
um so yeah what's your take on
distracting writing i i think that
there's a bit
of of cultural um
cultural context at play as well because
you know
it's it's also biohazard
right so being able to
understand that it's a game that's being
developed for
uh essentially two unique cultures so
you have the web the east and the west
are making the same game it's true i
guess japanese
like if you watch a lot of anime there's
also a similar kind of like irreverence
juxtaposed with
horror that is not uncommon
there that's that also has that same
kind of tonal
hard shift
that that i i suppose i am
uh sidestepping that and at one point i
did think i i said i i wonder
if this is less whiplashy
in japanese um well yeah and i don't
know the answer to that
some stuff could also be like i don't
know how to translate
that you know that's what i mean what
you're going to say so it's
and i don't think that probably at that
level
if people have the ability to go can we
write your own game and we're going to
write our own game
and we're going to have but i do know
the performers in that went to japan
and shot it there so it wasn't that it
was
shot by japanese actors in japanese
and then it was uh
definitely some of it was shot in l.a
on a stage in l.a i interviewed um lady
dee
uh on on my youtube channel welcome
ladies and gentlemen and she said it was
uh
in l.a and part was yeah good enough
i to be to be clear i i liked the game i
mean i
stuck with it and i i'm at a point in my
life where if i don't like a game i do
not stick with them i bail immediately
and i i made it all the way to the end
but it was an interesting case study of
like
i'm liking this in spite of the cheese
and
the cheese is clearly a calculated
choice which is why i was curious if
that's a thing but it's really only
you guys because i don't feel like the
villains are cheesy i didn't feel like
ethan yeah
he's the he's he is the
the worst offender but it still has very
hammy like
i will destroy you kind of in the box
for sure but i feel like generally like
you know heisenberg
when he's just talking to you i didn't
think he felt very andrew ryan to me
very andrew ryan i didn't think that he
was he was super cheesy i don't think
lady d is very cheesy
except when you're being chased and
she's talking about you being a man
thing or whatever
again like when you meet when you meet
uh again i guess this is a spoiler but
but uh
uh when you meet up with uh redfield and
he's he's ethan's like why didn't you
explain any of this to me and he was
like because i knew you wouldn't
you would like you would intervene you'd
try to help and it's like
well anyway yeah that plan failed
miserably yeah they're all pretty
incompetent
actually well and then because then the
next thing he does is like
don't take on uh um heisenberg alone
it's too dangerous and i'm like
i beg your pardon i have just worked my
way through all of these characters
oh he's also like just in full spoiler
territory he's also like be super quiet
he has this tank please don't blow your
cover
take the giant mech that i've given you
you're like what but it's just
the idea that the argument was you can't
handle it it's too dangerous
and i'm still gonna stick with that
after you've basically massacred all the
bad guys and we're in the 11th hour of
this
adventure i just thought but redfin
didn't
know what was up with
ethan i don't think
which is the thing that justifies why
he's so invincible
no i get it but but your track record by
that point you've beaten like five
bosses
sure um and and he must see he seemingly
knows that they leave laptops everywhere
they do leave left
everywhere they must have carried in
like
giant freight trains of laptops to just
scatter them around all these like
hidden dungeons and stuff
and then they just leave all of them
just keep leaving this [ __ ] everywhere
they're all running during this guy
what do you keep [ __ ] leaving these
laptops around for
holy [ __ ] we have a very high laptop
budget
yeah it's ridiculous but yeah that's
really really that's what i mean i had
such a great time
so did i and at some point i enjoyed the
absurdity of these things that i'm kind
of picking apart about it but that's why
i was curious if those kinds of things
can make you go
i'm sorry this is just too silly like
like
can can the raw gameplay float it at
that point where you're like i just i
enjoy shooting these creepy ass
zombies and these boss fights and and
like looking for
you know crafting ammo like at some
point am i checked out of the narrative
but the gameplay itself sustains i think
that happens often
and i think you know that's a problem we
have with a lot of studios not
prioritizing writing to an extent that
you just kind of tune the writing out
and sometimes i just don't even know
what's happening if i put something down
for two weeks and i come back and i do
i do think that's pretty frequent and i
don't think it matters as long as the
gameplay holds it
the only time that writing really really
bothers me
um definitely happened with metal gear
solid 4
who's the the most glaring example of a
game that i had to walk away from
because i got so annoyed
is when which isn't even necessarily the
writing team's fault
uh cutscenes interrupt gameplay too
frequently
where it was like that game was very
much like walk for a minute cut scene
crawl under a car cutscene i'm just like
take
away the interaction or give me the
interaction yeah
yeah just make a choice because having
it taken away and given back like with
such frequency based on such tiny things
i found
really frustrating and that's the only
time that really bothers me i think
that's what killed me on death stranding
uh like i couldn't the first three hours
of gameplay was 50
cutscenes and i was like i can't
keep this up it's nice it's a kojima
thing he does that
yeah and that's honestly not not that he
needs my defense but
what he's going for is like i understand
that i'm contributing to the game space
and yes i'm a game designer and a game
developer but
what i'm trying to do is bridge these
two worlds together
so that it's both bridges so i i get
that you and you're gonna you're gonna
disenfranchise both people right but
people who don't play games gonna go i'm
not gonna play a game people play
against like i wanna watch a movie
um somebody making something that's
distinctly different and i mean i asked
him one time i was like why don't you
just make movies and he said games are
harder
it was like probably true you're wrong
with the especially the crazy-ass kind
of games that he likes to make like
yeah i've i've i have respect for him in
that way way easier
yeah wait it's funny it's funny because
i really
as a player i much prefer like purely
experiential
games like i really like you know gone
home or something that doesn't really
there's zero cut scenes like it's all
what you do and that's like more and
more my taste in games
um but that said like the last of us
you know is hours and hours of cut
scenes and i was there for every
every minute of it so like i think it
also is dependent on the
caliber of the writing obviously to hold
that up and most games just don't
have that level of writing but like gone
home it may not have cut scenes but it
still has a lot of content audio-wise
there's still stuff that is interrupting
your it's not interrupting though that's
the thing i think that's the key
that's like the bioshock audio logs
where you
you click it but you keep roaming around
and you keep doing your thing and that
as a vehicle for
narrative you know deployment
is so effective for me at least like i
said
either if you play quantum break yes
the fact that it had uh live-action
chunks and i feel like people are pretty
troy
people are pretty mixed on that i ended
up really like not troy
because i played through the gameplay
and then i would watch like my little
episode of tv and then that would be the
end of my play session for the night
that's how i played three i get that but
to me
it just
i don't like the incorporated like her
story notwithstanding or
or there's other sam barlow
um i believe that stick with your
aesthetic
but this notion of like it drove me
crazy honestly even in
dude oh you've been happy yeah i'm good
even like the in
shadow of of of war and shadow of mordor
the disparity between or advanced
warfare was another example too
the disparity between game and
cut scene towards like cutscene was
polished and
and the the level of fidelity was
higher but of course you couldn't do
that so
certain scenes got a little bit more
love than others and the rest of them
kind of relegated to the to the
b team that was a complete call it was
like these are big moments so we really
want to
you know commit more of our resources to
them and i don't i don't envy the
position that the developer had to be in
for either of those games because it's a
tough one you want to look
[ __ ] awesome and you do especially
like with with lord of the rings you're
going up against the standard of peter
jackson
but for me it's like we're not going to
be able to beat peter jackson we can't
do it so instead
keep everything down here it's like yeah
but then again this goes back to the
very beginning of the conversation
marketing doesn't get their piece to be
able to put on the tv trailer going holy
[ __ ] that looks incredible look at that
dragon
but but shadow were it really shadowed
mordor but shadow of war kind of went up
thinking
of this a little bit more where
i i love that game like i j whether
i'm not i'm in it or not no that game is
great it is very very good
it is just so it is one of my most like
i'm just going to drop drop in and play
something i can walk away from any time
that i want or i can just invest as much
time in it as i want
but the thing that still drives me crazy
is i'm off doing this one
thing and then man like that son of a
[ __ ]
great walker you're like [ __ ] you know
it's those things
interrupting and then it would then
especially if i'm like
i am in a flow i've got that arkham type
combat to where i'm disordered the you
know assassin's creed thing where like
i'm feeling a flow i'm definitely moving
very quickly through this i'm feeling
like a badass
and then a captain walks in and then
over here and then i have to listen to
his like
i remember when you walked in my life
and my life was
let me tell you who i am first of all i
am the third son of the house and
they're like
[ __ ] shut up so i definitely i
hate it when something become a feature
of the game becomes an
interruption or an encumbrance upon my
specific
um playing a playstyle
but does that mean that i don't want
that feature there at all like at what
level and how
no one could know or at least maybe they
should have known
you're doing game tests right you should
be getting enough data to come back go
people are
trying to that we get button detection
where people are trying to cut
through you know they're trying to
bother a lot of people they would have
known
they definitely it's so interesting that
subject of
the um the disparity of um
[Music]
um like cinematics to gameplay
it's so interesting just a little
tangent off of that
playing the legendary edition of mass
effect it's so fascinating
how over the course of the three games
those two
the the narrowing between those is so
dramatic like
from the cut scenes in the first one
relative to the gameplay
it's it's just so vastly more cinematic
and
and sort of you know set pc and then the
gameplay is a little bit more
considerably more stiff and then they
raise the bar
a lot with the second one and like the
cameras you know subtly move in dialogue
and stuff and
the raw gameplay starts to feel more
cinematic but then by the time of the
third one
where it it's just that it's almost
seamless like it's not
perfectly seamless because they have
pre-rendered cut scenes where they don't
show your party and they don't show
shepard
um that they interweave with the the
gameplay in order to show your shepherd
but then it'll cut to like
the reaper you know next to the shroud
on tuchanka and it's like
that suddenly the frame rate is
different and stuff because it's like a
pre
it's like a canned cutscene and it's but
it's
considering the ambition relative like
the amount of
one upsmanship in from one to two to
three of like
let's just keep raising the bar is
really staggering but multiplayer is
real good too
good trilogy as it turns out yeah well
and even the caliber of like the action
uh and the like as a shooter the third
one is
genuinely a good like it's it's a good
game like it's a really like it's not
it's not a vehicle for a great narrative
the way the first one kind of
a little bit is fantastic storytelling
i love them ravenously like it's maybe
my favorite
sort of taken as a trilogy in one it's
sort of
maybe my favorite ever uh but but it's
so fascinating how the first one
i really thought they i know we talked
about this a little bit i really thought
the first one would be more
updated to be like the others uh than it
is but
um but yeah anyway i can sometimes have
issues with things being too seamless in
terms of cutscenes though um
like the oh yeah to come out 2016 i
think tomb raider
it was very impressive the first time
but it basically will
begin or end a cut scene and go straight
into
you having to control lara say say she's
going through a cave and she's walking
through it and then suddenly she just
stops and that's how you know you're
supposed to take control again and that
game does that a lot
to the extent that i was like i don't
know do i am i doing this
am i walking up this tower right now or
is the game doing this and i found that
to be a little bit jarring because it
was so seamless
they transitioned them just without any
cut
to the extent that i was like what this
is me now this i'm okay this is me this
part is me when do i pick up the
controller
i remember liking that game i couldn't
remember i like the whole trilogy
because god of war obviously
is like raised the bar dramatically on
the notion of there being no
differentiation
between those and it never it never
pulled me out of it
but i feel like it is still the framing
is often
distinct enough that when you get back
into you controlling it camera
pulls out a little bit or you know it
has to go behind kratos's back again or
whatever else
where with tomb raider it's exactly the
same you just have to press
the the mic yeah like the the yeah funny
enough mass effect 3 does that a lot too
where
there will be a lot of dialogue and a
lot of stuff right up until you're
supposed to take control and the camera
always does this
swing around and landing in that third
person
camera perspective and and it obviously
the ui
and [ __ ] pops up yeah too which makes it
very obvious but even without that
you you feel like i always you know
would like have my coffee so i'd like
go grab my coffee during the cut scene
and you have a few seconds heads up
before
the gameplay starts because of that
camera move always sort of
cueing you that it's never just cut
straight troy can you speak to that
you've directed cinematics
how do you approach ending the cinematic
you always have to understand where
is what happens to the player character
after this and it definitely
controlled my blocking my camera
because it was like if you ever did a
thing where
and then they walk out of frame there's
going to be then
then what happens you know typically
what happens is
we would always like italian's a perfect
example in shadow war but always at the
end
typically on a shot of of italian
because then we would come back around
behind him
so it felt weird to have him leave
and now where are you putting him in the
same way
of triggering a cut scene
where are you in relationship to where
you just were
so it's it's always weird like you know
gta does this there's a lot of things
where it's like hey these are optional
whenever there's an open world game
that's like we're going to
if you if you click x on this
you're going to store x you know is
going to you know start this mission
we have you enter from a different place
we have you
all of a sudden now you're warping down
to this place
even though it doesn't start here um
even though
we may return you back to this same spot
when it's
actually out of that that cinematic but
a lot of times
we have to go back in and reshoot stuff
so you're like so
we shot it this way but actually this is
gonna be this has been moved down here
so now we need to
have a change here but it it definitely
camera placement and blocking are are
driven
by those things of this one when people
say it's seamless i'm like
that's bananas like if you're able to
pull that off
um that is that is such a forward
thinking
three as we all say all the time like
playing three-dimensional chess
because you're constantly thinking about
design um
player agency camera all of that stuff
so it's it's a that's tricky that's
really really tricky
science builders for the win i mean
there's also like the interesting
challenge of um
if you just let players have full agency
over a cutscene what they will do like
in half-life
but then generally they will just jump
all over the place and crawl at things
and ruin any dramatic delivery because
they're kind of changing
the timing by moving around the room
banging your crowbar on
exactly getting no reaction you're still
technically getting the information but
i feel like the silliness of it can
completely ruin
the actual delivery of whatever
information or even the tone of a scene
because you're giving the players too
much control and everyone when you have
control
you want to do something like if i'm
just stuck somewhere i'm gonna tap a to
jump or whatever else you know like that
is a thing that you want to do you don't
want to just sit there and be delivered
to it's almost like
you'd prefer the cutscene then limitless
the opportunity to play around yeah
that's why a lot of times what they'll
do is they'll put them as like this
on a corridor you're on a forest walk
which is yeah
because the war does it a lot you're
walking out a hallway getting
information through the
walkie-talkie thing like it's a you have
to control them somehow
mass effect 3 also uh does it i think a
pretty good job
of not making you lose your mind from
like it takes away you can't draw your
gun
you can't roll you just can only walk
and sort of half-pace sprint
um while people are talking yeah um and
it doesn't feel like it i you know
normally
again it would feel i think players
would get frustrated like i want to be
able to draw my gun
and there but by by selectively pulling
back on that bit of agency
it it forces you to stick with the kind
of immersive
storytelling in a way that feels a lot
less forced than a cut scene
yeah certainly um and i like that
again the third one does that far more
effectively than the second one i think
in general
yeah yeah i gotta run yep cool
thanks for answering my question about
games almost as good as their writing
yeah we really spoke about video games
today look at us go anyway bye troy
and bye everyone else we will see you
all next week
how does that go so high how tall
it's a desk that was designed for lady
demisha machine yes stupid
as they call her